all right thank you very much for the
introduction thank you all for being
here I'm quite excited to be actually
back in this room I was here more or
less exactly one year ago already giving
a talk
um and I'm really looking forward to
talk to you today about anchors which is
a nice expandable AI method that allows
you to uncover
um not so much what a machine learning
model is looking at but what a machine
learning model relies on to make its
decisions
um so in general just to give you a
rough idea what's the big question so we
do we're quite often faced with with a
situation that we do have a machine
learning model that takes some input
Maps into some output and then either we
as the people creating it or somebody
who's trying to audit it or even the
users that are interacting with the
system they wonder why this is actually
happening or they might come to you and
they wonder why in the under these
circumstances did your model do
something and that's a very big question
um and there are many different ways
that you can answer this why and anchors
is just one of many ways in which we can
do that
we have a lot on our agenda today what
we're going to do is to first talk about
what's an anchor in more general terms
so what's the basic idea then we will
talk about how we can Define these
anchors in terms of rule sets then we
will look at basic strategies for
finding them right so how do we find out
what a model relies on then we will take
a bit of a more of a deep dive into a
multi-unbanded algorithm that allows us
to do this efficiently and finally we'll
be able to assemble a complete anchor
algorithm
now if you've looked at the extended
abstract you will have seen that it
mentions that I would actually be or we
together would actually be coding up
such an algorithm today from scratch
unfortunately turns out it's not
possible at least I couldn't find a way
to do this in 20 minutes while also
making sure that we cover all the
concepts that are really important to
understand and so I hope you agree with
me that it's the right decision to
instead focus on these Concepts to
really Grog them rather than trying to
code up a basic um basic version and
then everything flies over your head
um so um but even even without coding
there's a lot on the agenda so let's
Jump Right In
what is an anchor
um if you look at this picture
and you try to figure out in which
country this picture was taken if you
just look at this
um most of you will immediately know or
guess that this is a picture from
Germany
um and then if you uh if you wonder how
how do you know that how did you figure
this out I mean there are a lot of
things you can look at right the houses
the cars maybe the the traffic signs but
there's one thing which is a which kind
of gives it away which is this orchard
right so this yellow um this yellow sign
in the center that's very typical for
Germany that doesn't exist anywhere else
in the world and so independent of what
else is in the picture and what else
you've been looking at this is really
where you anchor your decision on that
this is probably most likely a picture
from Germany
another example would be this guy
um quite quite a Timeless picture in
principle right gray background wears a
suit wears a white shirt it's not really
possible to really guess
um where this is and also not when this
picture was taken but I guess most of
you will be able to kind of time that
picture put it like on a timeline put it
on the calendar
just because for the sole reason that
this guy has an iPhone in his hand and
so we know that this cannot possibly
have been taken prior to the existence
of iPhones right so this is not a
picture from the 90s and this is also
not the early 2000s but it has to be
post 2007.
um and so even if you don't know who
that is or where this could have
possibly been taken just the fact that
there's an iPhone in that picture kind
of dates it
and so this is the general colloquial
concept of an anchor this is something
which as long as that is present as long
as this is in the picture for example
you will maintain that decision and
would be really really difficult to
convince you that for example this
picture was actually taken in 1985.
anchors can also be interesting right um
for example if you look at this picture
at first glance you might think that's
Paris right there's the Eiffel Tower
and you wouldn't necessarily be wrong
right um but this picture has actually
been taken in Las Vegas
um but if somebody came to you and said
well I think that's a picture from Paris
you probably wouldn't be so mad at them
when they point out well there's the
Eiffel Tower in the picture where else
could have possibly been taken
and these situations like this are
actually the ones where mostly in data
science these anchor algorithms are
really helpful because machine learning
models tend to make exactly these kind
of mistakes they look at a certain thing
they have seen a lot of samples from
pictures of the Eiffel Tower in Paris so
they locate this picture in Paris and
then actually once you know why was this
picture paste in Paris you can then go
and maybe augment your data set
um moving more towards machine learning
um we can refine our definition of an
anchor we'll be working through that
over the next minutes
um and say that we will define an anchor
as something that as long as it is
present in the input the model will
maintain it at its output right so as
long as there's the Eiffel Tower our
model will constantly tell us that's
Paris that's Paris that's Paris and uh
if we want to actually have it
recognized that also Eiffel Towers
exists elsewhere we need to add more
data
and the example we'll be working with is
not going to be an image but it's going
to be a sentence
um we will use a kind of a sentiment
analysis model and we'll use a sentence
which is python is the best programming
language
um to which this model assigns a
positive sentiment and using this
example we will try um or we will start
to understand how anchors can be
computed for that sentence
um
so far anchors are quite a vague term
right so we haven't really defined
defined an anchor in a way we've just
talked about it we've pointed at
pictures you maybe have a guess of where
the anchor sits in that sentence but we
need to be a bit more specific and the
way that anchor algorithms do this is by
creating rules um by or by defining
anchors in terms of rules and we can do
this immediately for our example
sentence
um by just coming up so we have six
words and so we can come up with six
rules um one rule for each word so does
the sentence contain the word python
does the sentence contain the word best
does the sentence contain the word
programming and so we have six rules
um and what's all what you will already
notice is that these rules cover the
entire sentence right and we we know
that probably one or two or three of
these rules so like the presence of
certain words is going to lead on to our
model
um or it's going to make our model
predict a positive sentiment for that
sentence
and so the question is which of these
six rules is it
um there are different types of rules
that you can use
um the simple simple version are binary
rules and that's anything which you can
encode as a true or false statement
um one example which we've already just
seen is the presence of a certain token
or the presence of a word we can also do
when we're working with images might be
the presence of a certain pixel or a
certain image segment right the Eiffel
Tower the iPhone the odds Shield or if
we're in the tabular numeric data space
it might be that there's a certain
feature that surpasses a given threshold
so let's say every time a certain value
is above a thousand we will make a
certain prediction
um of course
um there are infinitely many
possibilities of defining rules you can
also have more complex ones and I would
just Define everything that requires
more than one bit to encode as a complex
Rule and typical examples would be if
you have a feature a scalar feature that
has a lower and an upper bounds right so
if you sit in between a range then this
rule would apply or you maybe have a
categorical variable that can take on
multiple values and as long as it has a
value out of a subset then this could
also be a rule that is fulfilled or not
fulfilled
yeah
um and so we can continue refining the
definition of an anchor which is to say
that an anchor is a set of rules and as
long as all these rules are fulfilled
for a certain in foreign input then the
model will maintain its output so it's
not going to change from the original
um and this allows this definition
allows us to come up with our first
anchor of the day which is quite trivial
but also instructive to look at which is
just to say all of the rules that we
have should apply right we know that if
the sentence contains the words python
is the best programming language we get
a positive sentiment that is that
fulfills our definition right so we have
these six rules all of them apply we get
a positive sentiment but of course it's
not really helpful right so it doesn't
tell us anything more than what we have
already learned
so maybe we need to be a bit more
specific of what we want to find
and a good at least a good start is to
look for the smaller set of rules such
that this relationship that set of rules
applies to the input leads to the model
yielding a certain output that there's
holes with high probability and so we're
not interested in having many rules but
we want to find the smaller set of rules
and using our example we already can
make an assumption of how many rules we
might probably need and what this what
this should look like so the idea is
that we have the sentence python is the
best programming language our model
predicts a positive sentiment
um and intuitively we already would
assume that for example if we change the
programming language like Java is the
best programming language then this
might not be a true statement but
nevertheless the model will continue to
believe that this is a positive
statement
however if we switch out the word best
for the word worst then we will um we
would assume at least that we get a
negative sentiment and so quite likely
the anchor in this case would be does
the sentence contain the word best or
does the sentence contain the word
um or the the words the best for example
but um instead of just looking at
sentences how can we execute a computer
to find this also of course in more
complicated scenarios
and to find an anchor uh we use
something which is called a local beam
search or at least a local search
and that's a very common algorithm some
of you might have worked with that
during uh if you've got to have a
computer science degree you might have
learned about this or if you've done
work um yeah in general in search or in
in planning for example then search is a
quite a quite a common structure and
this works by just selecting one random
rule starting with one single random
rule in the beginning for example um
does the sentence contain the word
programming and then out of this rule
will derive the so-called Next
Generation
which we can for example generate by
just adding an additional random rule to
it so we have three possible children
um three possible new anchors that might
be anchors right and then we have these
three options and we can we can go
through and figure out which one of
these is most likely to give us a
positive sentiment so right this is the
word programming it is is it the word
programming in python or is it the words
programming in best and then if we do
this um and if we try this a lot of
times over time we will find out that
actually um the bottom one so if you if
it contains the word program and it
contains the word best that this is um
this is the best option and then we
could either stop or we could continue
and add yet another Rule and try to see
if we can get even better and even
closer
two things to note here
um you will see that if we just start
with one rule in the beginning
um we will never get rid of this word
programming even though it's probably
unrelated to what we're trying to figure
out so if in if you do this as a beam
search what you will do is that even in
the first generation you will start with
two or three or four different rules
right
um so so that you have independent
starting points
um and the second thing is how do we
actually know which of these we want to
keep right so each generation we want to
look at a lot of new versions and then
just keep a handful of them and then
evolve them further
and this is where these multi-armed
Bandits will come in eventually but
first let's zoom in and look at how do
we actually evaluate such an anchor
candidate right so how do we know
whether this might possibly be an anchor
um again taking the example of the
sentence contains the words programming
and best what we do is that we look
through a lot of sample sentences and
these can either come from a big body of
of text right so might you might have a
big text database or a big Text data set
which you can look through or you can
also generate them by modifying the
original sentence just swapping out
certain words or just deleting words
from the sentence and we will look
through all these sentences that we have
or these samples until we find a
sentence that matches our rules right
that fulfills the rule that it has to
contain the word best and it has to
contain the word programming and once
we've found that sentence we will then
go and feed this sentence into our model
and then the model will either say it's
a positive sentence or a negative
sentence and this this gives us some
hint right so then we learn a little bit
more about the set of rules it doesn't
tell us anything but at least it's a
sign
in either in one in either direction
um and to do this a little bit more
efficiently uh we can use so-called
multi-arm banded a multi-ambanded or
multi-unbanded framework and frame it as
such a problem and the idea of a
multi-arm banded very roughly speaking
is that we have different arms which in
our case are just the different
candidates
um different rule combinations and we
have certain beliefs about them right so
we we're trying to understand whether
these rules being fulfilled will lead to
a positive sentiment and we can we can
refine our beliefs or update our beliefs
by pulling these arms that just means
run the evaluation I just showed you and
then over time we will be able to update
our beliefs and get closer and closer
and closer to the true uh probability
and that's the um that's what we use to
rank and understand which of these
candidates we generated are actually uh
relevant
yeah and now um let's get to the um
the algorithm the specific algorithm
that is actually used within the anchor
explanation approach
um and this has a very strange name it's
called
kllucb multi-armed banded algorithm
um and um the first thing we we will do
is or what we'll do in the next couple
of minutes is to really decode what that
means
um and get an understanding
so the first part of the klucb stands
the KL stands for callback Lively
Divergence bounds we will not go into
too much detail of what colorback
library Divergence is but in very rough
terms it's something it's a measure for
checking how far apart two different
probability distributions are so if you
have one probability distribution and
another one it's a measure to to figure
out are they actually the same how how
different are they
um in and can you actually tell them
apart when you encounter them in real
life
and this is this is a basic measure that
underlies this mechanism in this
multi-unbanded algorithm and we will use
this concept to compute bounds
[Music]
because what what what's happening what
we have been doing so far is that we had
an anchor candidate and we checked it
end times right so we've we've I've
evaluated end times
um and then we will know that the model
um produced the desired outputs or the
positive sentiment in M cases
um and so very naively uh we would we
will believe that the probability that
this is a good um that this will um
produce a positive sentiment is just M
over n right so if we've seen it m times
out of n so this is our belief but of
course if you've just done this one once
or twice
um it's very unlikely that we have the
true probability right so it might be
that it just produces a positive
sentiment in five percent of the cases
where the rules are fulfilled and we've
just gotten unlucky that we've seen a
positive sentiment in the first two
attempts
and so using these Divergence bounds
what we will do is we can calculate a
lower and an upper bound on that
probability so we will figure out what's
the the lowest prop true probability and
the highest true probability that is
compatible with the observation that
we've had
um and roughly speaking the more times
we try the more it shrinks right so if
we tried a hundred times then we would
be pretty close to the actual true
probability
um yeah so that's the first part and
then the second part is this l u c b
that's the lower and upper confidence
bound
um because
um if you've uh if you remember the way
that we we evaluate all these different
anchor candidates is by checking the
model first of all we need to search
through a lot of text and then once we
find text that matches then we also need
to go and evaluate evaluate it by
actually sending a text to the model and
then receiving it and that's a very
expensive operation if we start with
let's say 10 different possible
candidates in the first generation and
then we generate three new ones out of
every candidate then we have 30 and we
need to shrink it down to 10 again this
will take us a lot of time and a lot of
compute and so we would like to minimize
the number of times we actually need to
query our machine learning model
and the way that we can do this in this
lucb setting is to um to do the
following procedure in order to find the
N best n candidates out of a set of
let's say two times n or three times n
the first thing is that we do is that we
sort the candidates based on our current
beliefs right so we have a very naive
understanding of how these would rank so
some we've never seen positive examples
for some we've only seen positive
examples for and so we will just rank
them in order from the best to the worst
and then instead of checking all of them
again we will just look at the end
candidates so the one we're just about
to keep and the N plus one candidate so
the one which we're just about to drop
and not consider further
um and we will only refine our beliefs
about these two candidates
um and what and then what might happen
is that they just stay in their place or
they swap positions or they move
somewhere entirely different and that's
fine but we will just continue doing
this over and over and over again
and what will then happen is that we
kind of have a leading pack so the top
let's say we keep 10 candidates so the
top 10 will start slowly start to move
away from the bottom pack and we will
continue repeating this until the lower
Bound for the nth candidate so like the
worst case scenario for the for the one
we're just about to keep and the upper
bound of the N plus one candidate so the
best case scenario for the one we're
going to throw away until there there
will there will be a gap that's forming
um and um once this surpasses a given
threshold there's a hyper parameter of
the algorithm we are fairly confident
that we've actually figured out which
are the best the best ones to keep and
then we'll use them in the next
um in the next iteration
and this way we can minimize the number
of queries we need to make to our model
yeah so then now we do actually have all
ingredients
um and we can assemble them together to
form an anchor algorithm
and the main components of an anchor
implementation are of course the model
so that's something which we need
obviously because that's what we want to
learn about
and then we have four components that we
need to need to create that might be
really simple they might also be very
intricate and one big problem with
anchor algorithms in practice is or one
challenge rather is that you um that you
can tune and tweak all of these
independently and so it can be quite
tricky to come up with a with a good
combination of parameters that reliably
generates what you're looking for
so the first part is the rule generator
right so far in the example that we've
talked about today we've mostly um we've
just like looked at single words we've
just looked for the presence of words
for example we haven't looked at word
order
these are all things which we could
potentially implement but we need
something which generates these rules
for a certain sample then we need the
search components the search component
and there I would say it's um the the
setup I showed you is fairly standard
but what I've shown you today is a very
simple version of generating this next
Generation so we've just been adding
rules we've never deleted rules
um potentially we could also do this
backwards right if we just have a really
short sentence we could just start with
all the rules in place and then just
take random ones out lots of different
possibilities you can also go into
evolutionary and genetic algorithms so
lots of things to explore there
and then in order to figure out which of
these anchor candidates to keep for the
Next Generation we used a multi-arm
banded algorithm uh usually based on
this klucb system which is mostly in
place to ensure that we don't need to
query our model that often and in order
for these multi-unbanded component to
work we need a sample generator so we
need either a database or some way of
generating these um yeah these Disturbed
sentences so that we can so that we have
something to evaluate against
and with that said we're I'm pretty much
in time
um and um also have a complete anchor
algorithm at our hands and so I would
like to thank you
um for your attention I'm really looking
forward to the discussion we are about
to have and um just um to um and there's
a GitHub repository for this talk which
contains both the slides and also a
fairly long list of links for further
reading links to implementation links to
research papers and more accessible
tutorials
um on this topic
um and I'm yeah looking forward to your
questions now thank you
[Applause]
thank you
right thank you we have a couple of
questions on the slider keep voting if
you want to upload your some questions
first one will it be possible to use a
priority Church like a rules to find the
best holiday world set instead of the
seemingly costly local Bim search Plus
lucb
um so to to use what exactly
um yeah so I'm not familiar with a rules
um with that concept but in general yes
um of you can you can go in with
whatever information you have
um and also depending on who you want to
show these um explanations to or what
you suspect
um that these anchors should look like
you can of course tweak your rules uh
according to that and the more you can
put in as a priori information the
better but on the other hand you also
have to make sure that you're actually
figuring out what the model is doing and
that you're not just creating something
which you believe that it should be
doing
thanks
um
for now I'm taking the question in order
because it's all zero Watts so please
look at the slide though and about if
you find
yeah I reviewed them
no
because I'm online I'm reviewing
I have I approved all the question facts
okay so let's go for the next one yeah
sure for what kinds of models and data
tabular images text would you most
recommend it using encourse uh I think
the um
I think actually as a it works for all
of them where it's quite helpful is for
tabular data but there the rules are a
bit more complicated but there it's
really nice because you can also then go
and search through your um through your
data set and find other real samples
that fulfill these these conditions and
then this also allows you to to compute
the coverage right so you know how many
um like do these rules only apply to a
very specific subset or is this actually
very general for your entire data set
okay skip this one is the same what
framework do you recommend for
production use
um that's that's uh a difficult question
so in my experience it actually makes if
you really want to use that it actually
makes sense to more or less
um code this up in the specific uh way
that you need it
um so you can use the scale at UCB
algorithms that's like a fairly small
function also the search is not super
difficult to implement but everything
else is really really has to be tailored
to your use case right so like the rule
generation uh the way that you you
perform the search and generate the next
um yeah the next generation of potential
candidate is something where it makes
sense uh to if you need this in a
performant fashion to really code this
up yourself and the most mature
implementation that I know of is in The
Alibi package by Selden which is also
linked in the GitHub repository nice
um oh do the anchors generalize how well
do they work on unseen data
data
um
that uh I would say that depends right
so if you um if your model is quite
consistent
um in what it's doing and the the
examples that you generate these anchors
for uh are also like well within what
the model can handle uh then they do
generalize quite well
um otherwise you're doing something
wrong in generating them but the idea is
to find out like to find the general
rules and of course that's easier for
example in tabular data rather than in
image data just because the
dimensionality of of your images is way
higher it's almost magnitude higher than
let's say for a tabular data set
nice
um just for the audience a quick
question do you still not be able to
vote on the slider
I'm really sorry because I'm approving
everything
and I'm connected to the Wi-Fi so
um so next one do you think this fits a
classification model with Android plus
continuous numerical input features
um that's probably uh
computationally expensive but there's no
reason why this shouldn't work it will
just take a really long time in general
they only anchors only work for
um for classification but if you for
example have a regression model or
something which is quite close to
regression model there's always a way to
like turn it into a classification
Problem by discretizing the output and
potentially also by discretizing the
input so if you come if you have
continuous scalar inputs what you
usually do is that you divide this up
either like in 10 10 segments of the
same or 10 intervals of the same size or
you can base this on some statistical
property of your data but you will not
have a rule that that has like a precise
value in the beginning but you need to
chop it up in a way that's suitable to
the domain you're working in
okay and next one is can you explain the
difference to our principal component
analysis
I can try
um yeah so the the principal component
um
analysis
or that that's a tricky question
um but I would say that this is has more
to do with the with the data right
rather than with with what a model is
doing so the advantage here and of
course if you can do a principle
component analysis on your data and then
this also has something to do with your
um
it also like affects the prediction kind
of
um then then you're more like on the
modeling side of things whereas here we
are we're faced with a model we know
nothing about right so we we just have
some Black Box model which we can we can
do nothing but probe it
um so I would say that
um
yeah that's essentially unrelated
Concepts as well yeah but if anybody
knows more about this it has a different
opinion curious to learn about that
okay
um do you have some example of applying
uh anchors to computer vision
um
yes I think
um so um in general um so there are some
examples even in the original paper of
how to do this
um and the the basic
um
the basic idea is actually quite close
to to what we've done here right so it's
about classifying
um
classifying images and figuring out
which parts of the image you can black
out or or replace and that can be quite
instructive for example what you can if
you if you're afraid that for example
what your classifier is looking at is
actually for example some text in the
image and so I think there are some
common cases from the um yeah from
Medical Imaging where they figured out
that actually what the machine learning
models were looking at were like some
some information written in text on
x-rays rather than structures in the
x-rays and this is something where it
might be difficult to see this with
feature importance methods because just
like humans I mean we also look at
essentially the entire image but then
still base our decision on a single fact
and there for example anchors are quite
nice to figure out these kinds of Errors
where you um were actually focused on
something or the entire decision depends
on let's say
um yeah the credits in the bottom lower
left instead of actual image content
okay so last question for
um speaking about feature importance can
we extract feature importance with
anchor can we can provide the impact way
in weight of every rule
um
so in uh in principle anchors and
feature importance are two different
different ways of expanding models also
because they ask two different questions
right future importance as which input
features had a positive or negative
influence on the specific output and
anchors ask what's kind of the deal
breaker right so what's the what's the
part that as long as it's there no
matter what else we change
um uh it will lead to the same output
and for example if we start to remove
parts of that image in this hypothetical
scenario then the feature importance
measures will change drastically right
so if you black out half the image our
feature importance distribution if you
do shape or lime might look very very
different from what it would look for
this image but the anchor will stay the
same so it's just two different two
different approaches two different
questions
um but of course you can then look at
what's the feature importance within
your anchor there are probably lots of
ways to combine the two but in general
it's two very different approaches
suitable for different purposes
great thank you kylian thank you
foreign
[Applause]